hi welcome to next
my name is jason joel and i'm a product
manager with google cloud i'm presenting
here today with my peer assigo pollen
and in this session we will deep dive
into the tools and services
to accelerate your migration to google
cloud
there are several motivators that lead
customers to migrate to the cloud and
modernize their applications and
infrastructure
many customers begin by wanting to use
the cloud to increase the speed of
innovation and address customer
requirements faster
but often the project is initially
justified by an impending financial need
like an upcoming hardware refresh a
significant business event such as an
acquisition
or an upcoming deadline like an expiring
data center contract
but it turns out migrating and
modernization
to the cloud is hard
enterprise migration projects often face
delays and go over budget
but this is typically because customers
do not understand the applications that
they are trying to migrate
they do not have a good plan that
includes moving all of their data
and they generally underestimate the
scale
at google we have a proven four-step
methodology
to help our customers
and meet them where they are and
accelerate their path to the google
cloud
platform
actually it's not a four linear steps
but
this is more of a process that will be
followed iteratively throughout the
migration journey
the first step is the assessment phase
and for this assessment phase google has
a tool called
stratazone and stratazone enables you to
do five things as part of your
assessment
first and foremost it helps you discover
what workloads applications and virtual
machines that you have that you want to
migrate to the cloud and build an
inventory as a place to start in a
baseline
the second thing it does is it evaluates
each of your workloads for its
suitability for the cloud gives you a
cloud fit score and helps you identify
what
remediations you may need to take in
order to move it
the third part of the stratazone process
is optimizing your consumption plan
and identifying where the best place is
to move a particular application to
google
google offers many services and it's not
always obvious where best workload the
best location is to move
and give you the biggest impact for your
money
the fourth step
is actually providing you with a roi a
real plan a return on your investment
paper that you can share with your
enterprise and share with your
executives and your stakeholders to get
an idea of what the return on their
investment will be and the benefits
they'll gain from moving to the cloud
and the last step of the strata zone
consumption plan
is developing this
to provide you with insights into what
you should move first second and third
in your journey
let's look at some of the key features
of stratazonic data collector in itself
it's agentless it does not require you
to install any software in each of your
virtual machines or on your physical
machines
all the information you send is
encrypted in transit and at rest
it's very lightweight so it doesn't put
any burden on your environment
and in fact the data that it transfers
is roughly less than 400 kilobits in
size
you have the option to anonymize any
data that you think might be sensitive
including ip addresses and machine names
and it's overall not intrusive you can
control the scope of the discovery that
you run from a single application to a
single data center to a multi-data
center migration
one of my peers aldruciac will now give
you a short demo on how stratazone works
stratosphere assessments can scale
globally with multiple data collections
feeding data from various customer
locations
the assessment relies on inventory and
telemetry data and is conducted within
the stratazone portal
all data is encrypted in transit and at
rest
no actual business confidential data is
collected such as data classified as pci
or hip-hop
once the assessment collection has begun
you will be able to see the results
populate within the stratazone portal
results include overall utilization
levels age of the machines details about
operating systems and cloud migration
compatibility scoring among others
you will also be able to review detailed
inventory in each machine's detail such
as its name ip address and configuration
specs
you will be able to further drill down
into utilization installed software and
running processes
network connectivity maps will be
available for any point-to-point
detected connections they can be viewed
in graphical form as well as in the
table form which represents details
about source and target ips ports and
processes such as sql server in this
case responsible for the connection
socket
detailed pricing views are available for
each assessed location application group
or migration group
within the groups machines are evaluated
individually based on the recorded
utilization and user-defined
right-sizing profiles each machine's
cost breakdown can be viewed in detail
to determine compute storage and egress
costs pricing can be generated for a
variety of different catalogs including
gc predefined types custom shapes sole
tenancy and gcv
committed and sustained discounts are
included in the calculation custom
discounting can also be defined by the
user
pricing can also be tailored to relevant
gcp regions stratazone also stores
industry benchmark costs for operating
on-premises data centers which can be
used in comparisons to device the most
suitable pricing scenarios at any point
in the assessment a customizable deck
can be generated in the reporting
dashboard
it can be fully customized to include
the relevant workload groups
optimizations pricing catalogs and
discounts
this assessment summary can serve as a
leave behind customer deliverable and a
proposal
this stack will cover the assessment
approach and findings along with pricing
information
findings are presented for all assets or
broken down by user configurable groups
solutions such as databases and app
engines will be identified along with
potential gcp targets
tco reports will be generated to provide
meaningful comparisons
after completing the assessment stage
you enter the planning phase
google has a planning methodology that
helps
make initial progress quickly reduce
risk and stay on budget
stratazone can help you arrange
migration candidates in order of
priority
based on business impact and the
migration effort that's required
a large migration will have many ways
with velocity increasing as the
migrations progress and experience your
organizations
by categorizing your workloads into
waves based on these two parameters you
can iterate
learn from those iterations and then
optimize your process
with stratazone's cloud readiness report
you can see which assets are high medium
and low fit for moving to the cloud
this is based on characteristics such as
capacity performance
age
operating system
and other machine based attributes
now psy will explain the tools that
google has to help you with the migrate
phase of your journey
thank you jason hi i'm psy and i'm a
product manager with google cloud let's
jump right in when we look at migrations
customers have specific paths to
migrating to google cloud each migration
path has an increasing level of
transformation and therefore change
and we have a number of tools that can
help you with that for example in
addition to moving your specialized
workloads or vms to the cloud to the
google cloud bare metal solution or
google cloud vmware engine or compute
engine or to gke
you may want to move your unstructured
archival data from an on-premises file
system to the cloud and we offer a few
options including a fully online storage
transfer service and a dedicated
transfer appliance that can be shipped
to your data center
let's look at a few tools in more
details in the subsequent session
the first tool is migrate for compute
engine that's delivered as a service our
latest version delivers a google managed
cloud service that enables simple
frictionless and large scale enterprise
migration of virtual machines to compute
engine with minimal downtime and risk
hundreds of vms fast to start this is a
replication-based tool which means that
it's predictable as well
api driven and integrated into your
google cloud console for ease of use you
can do your end-to-end migration
through the google cloud console
this service use agentless replication
to copy data without manual intervention
and without vpn requirements
it also enables you to launch
non-disruptive validations of your vms
prior to cut over
you can rapidly migrate a single
application or execute a sprint with 100
systems using migration groups with
confidence
there are six easy steps you enable your
api you deploy a migration connector
onboard and initiate replication set
your vm target perform your test and cut
over users can test their workloads
pre-cut over by creating clones of the
workload from the replicated data in the
cloud without disrupting the source
workload it also adapts the migrating
workloads automatically to run natively
in the cloud
and it includes
network settings and installation of
cloud agents for seamless integration
with cloud services post migration as
well
it supports migrating workloads to
different target configurations on the
fly for example users can test clone a
workload in project a while doing a cut
over of the same workload to project b
let us now hear from rackspace in their
experience with this tool
the tool that we love the most at
rackspace is google's migrate for
compute engine it's a super easy tool
for taking your environment that's
on-prem in a vmware environment and
migrating that to google but what's
amazing is that it's not like some tools
where it's like hey here's your
limitations and we can only do a or b
they can do everything like it allows
our customers to plan properly it lets
our it resources focus on running their
company and helping their end users
while we just use the tool to do what
it's supposed to do which is migrate and
then we're done it's very easy
we love it i cannot say enough good
things about how well it works with the
technology environments
what a great video from our partner
rackspace now migrate for compute engine
enables users to group vms based on
their needs and scenarios and execute
migration operations on a group level as
well as a subset of the group this
flexibility allows for you to edit the
migration details for one or many of the
vms in the group and perform replication
test cloning and cut over as well
let us now look at the life cycle of the
app
it starts with onboarding the vm which
means telling the tool that it's ready
to start replication and once you start
replication an initial sync happens all
of this without disruption to the source
vms
this is followed by continuous
replication thereafter
you can also perform non-disruptive
testing with test cloning there is no
disruption to the on-premises vn and
it's always a good idea to validate that
your vm will run correctly in the cloud
finally you cut over to the cloud during
say a scheduled maintenance window this
is when the source vm is powered off a
final sync of the vm data is done to the
cloud and that's it
let us now look at a quick demo of this
tool
in this demo i will walk through a quick
overview of migrate for compute engine
that's delivered as a google managed
service this means that you do not have
to manage the life cycle of the tool
i will cover the sources the migration
tab
and how you can perform bulk operations
with groups
here we see the main dashboard of
migrate for compute engine that's
completely integrated into our cloud
console it shows an overview of the
migrations the events the sources the
groups
and the target
let's go to the sources tab
in the sources tab i can see that i have
multiple on-prem data centers that act
as sources of virtual machines that i
want to migrate from
for each one of these sources
i can actually see that i have the vm
inventory cached in the system
this allows you to
execute end-to-end migrations without
ever leaving the console
migrate for compute engine uses
replication
to
migrate the virtual machines data over
to the destination or the target
as you can see over here
there are virtual machines that are
ready for replication there are virtual
machines that are active which means
that there is periodic replication
that's ongoing in the background
and there is a virtual machine that's
already been cut over
let's go into the migrations tab
this is the place where i do all of my
migration operations
i can see the status of all my
migrate migrating vms
i can go into
the info panel and edit the details of
my
migration
virtual machine
here i've selected w12 core and what i
can do over here is i can my i can edit
the my landing zone of the migrating vm
and i can also
select a vm
and perform migration operations
actions include
starting the replication
pausing the replication resuming the
replication finalizing the replication
it also includes
testing
the virtual machine with no impact to
the source vm in order to validate that
the workload in the cloud is running
correctly
and finally cutting over with minimal
downtime
many customers also want to migrate
virtual machines in bulk
the group
feature allows you to do that
here i see that i have actually grouped
three virtual machines
in a group called myapp1
groups enable you
to execute operations in bulk
such as bulk editing of migration
details
test clone and cut over
here
i can see that i can select all my vms
or a subset of them
and perform
bulk editing of migration details on all
of them
i can also do test cloning and cut over
for all of these at one go or a subset
of these
this brings us to the end of a quick
overview demo
now many customers want to migrate their
vmware workloads to a native vsphere
environment running in the cloud to
increase the agility and reduce costs
google cloud vmware engine solves this
problem and gives you a fast forward to
your journey to the cloud it is one of
the fastest ways to migrate your vmware
applications to the cloud and vmware hcx
is the tool that enables this it's
provided as part of vmware engine and it
abstracts the underlay infrastructure
and offers many options including hot
cold and warm migration options in bulk
now many customers also want to fast
forward to modernizing their
applications with migrate for anthos you
can transform your vms to containers
that is managed by anthos
with migrate for gke you can transform
your vms to containers that's managed by
gke in either standard mode or autopilot
mode
finally you can transform your vms to
containers that's managed by cloud run
so you can get started with the
serverless architecture
right off the bat
once more this happens in a simple six
step process you qualify a vm configure
the processing cluster to examine the
source vm and create a migration plan
that you then review and customize then
you use the processing cluster to simply
execute the migration plan and generate
your deployment yamls your container
images your data volumes we verify that
the workload is migrated correctly by
running some tests and finally deploy
the container artifacts to your testing
staging and production clusters you can
migrate from vmware on-premises aws
azure or even within gce
now once you've migrated you want to be
able to keep optimizing your environment
we have a tool called vm manager that
allows you to manage large fleets of vms
running windows or linux you can manage
your os patches perform and perform
compliance reporting on os patches
install remove and maintain agents apps
and configurations or in other words
manage your os configurations and also
use this service to collect runtime os
information
we also have a technology called active
assist now active assist is a portfolio
of tools that uses data intelligence and
machine learning to reduce cloud
complexity and administrative toil
making it easy for you to optimize your
cloud environment
whether you're interested in security
cost networking compute data or
operations we have the intelligence for
you
some new active assist features include
idle resource recommendations compute
committed use discount recommendations
and more
so what are you waiting for you can
start with a quick assessment that's
offered at no additional cost you will
receive a detailed inventory of your
virtual and physical server assets and
database estate and a customized total
cost of ownership report for moving to
the cloud as well as a detailed
end-to-end migration plan
this brings us to the end of this
presentation on behalf of jason and i we
thank you for watching this session
you